pressé m us et dit essayer de rassembler
suffisamment d'éléments auprès de karine
pourtant des de tous les clients et
enlèvement l'enlèvement souci numéro un
de son avocate préoccupé pour l'instant
parent csq gossip et par les rails
on chez eux
le fond du dossier vous savez si c'est
pour discuter de la fête l'attentât de
la la rue marbeuf vous en connaissez des
tenants et les aboutissants messieurs
ramirez sanchez a dit être étranger à
cette attente a balayé d'un revers de
main la centrale de la rue marc carlos
semble apparemment toujours aussi serein
face aux risques qu'il en est pourtant
l'étau se resserre sur ilitch ramirez
sanchez
mais là encore son éventuelle
implication dans les attentats du train
toulouse paris en 1982 et dans celui de
la gare saint charles à marseille en
1983 nous y aurait fait ni chaud ni
froid
mehdi salah pu sourire et ça l'a fait
il comprend pas ce point elle est très
tranquille je pense que on attribue
beaucoup de choses à carlo ni carlos n'a
pas l'air très inquiet par tous que la
justice française ne reproche son souci
ce matin éviter qu'on ne réveille toutes
les 20 minutes durant les rondes de nuit
il est fatigué et voudraient dormir